hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
another high definition video and today
we're going to be taking a look at
youtube.com as there is a been there's
been a recent update in youtube video
watch page uh it's not a very major
update but i do feel i need to point
this out to you guys uh well not the
need to point this out but i'd really
like to show you this because there uh
for the first time i can really say that
all the changes that have been made are
positive uh which is really impressive
uh for me to even say that i usually am
not you know
happy about every single thing i do but
all the things i've done are really good
so i'm taking a look at is a video i put
up about a week ago so it has
significant activity on it and you can
see over the top of the page really
hasn't changed that much but it's what's
underneath the video that's changed and
it's changed for the better so on the
right hand side you still have all of
your related videos which is where i
like to see them but what they've had
underneath the video typically you have
all the things spread out the entire
width of the video it separated them
into only being on the left hand side
and having related videos on the right
so now you have your like button now of
course ratings have been disabled on
this video but in between there you'll
be able to see
uh i'll give you a bad example i'll use
this video in between there you'll be
able to see how many likes and how many
dislikes the video has
similar to any other youtube videos so
if we hover over that you can see that
we can also do is click on that and view
the videos honors and insight and things
like that so i'll close that you can
also just like you can before have all
these add to options and sharing options
you can share the buzz you can share to
facebook twitter and uh if you still use
myspace i hope you get a virus
we also have the embed code and the flag
button you'll notice the view count is
actually a lot bigger than typically is
and if the video is not yours you won't
get this blue button but what i really
like is that every single thing that
expands including the description does
not disrupt the related videos so if you
actually planned on looking at a related
video to the right and you expand you
know you like the video it would
actually have moved down before and you
go ahead and take a look at the
description it would have moved even
further down but what i like is that it
doesn't actually move anything to the
right
in the related videos section or
suggestions so whenever you go ahead and
leave a comment it would push it down
it's just it got really cluttered and
you might lose your spot
so that's just something i felt like
pointing out to you guys of the new
youtube video page
there are a couple of hardware reviews
coming in the near future for mkbhd but
i felt like a screencast was a good
breath of fresh air so until next time
this has been mkbhd with a quick little
screencast for you guys and until then
until next time i'll talk to you later
peace